[Music]  are you ready are you ready ready e  t--'s Kevin Frazier on the ground in  London catching Prince Harry and Big  Brother Prince William as they enter  Windsor Castle ready just hours before  the Royal says I do too fiance Megan  Markel so how will the soon-to-be man  and wife spending hours leading up to  their nuptials royal expert Katie Nicol  dish to ET its traditional in the UK  that the bride and groom spend the night  before their wedding apart and Megan and  Harry and making sure they keep this  tradition Megan will be staying with her  mother at Clifton which is a very very  famous hotel if Harry will be William  who will be stealing Harry's nerves I  think at the cow with Park Hotel which  is just outside Windsor so neither bride  or groom are going to be in Windsor  Castle that treat will happen the night  of the wedding where I'm told the Queen  has made a beautiful suite available for  the couple and that's where they will  spend their first night as man and wife